sáng nay, kì học thứ mời, kì học củay cùng của những kì có khội khoảng 18, chính thức hai mặt tại nhà có khội, thủ đô Hà Nội.
Chức dự hai mặt, lãnh đạo đàn, nhà nước, mặt chẳng thủ của Việt Nam, các đại biểu có khội, đặt vòng hoa và vòng lăng viễn chủ tịch hồ Chí Minh.
Tham dự lế viễn có tổn bị thư tô lâm, chủ tính nước lương cường, thu tưởng phạm miệng chính, chủ tịch hồ Hội chân thành mắn.
Bùng dự có nhiều lãnh đạo đàn, nhà nước và các đại biểu có khội tham dự kì học thứ mời.
Vòng hoa của đoàn mang sòng trước, lời nơi nhớ hơn chủ tịch hồ Chí Minh viễn Đại.
Thác đại biểu đã bây tỏ lòng biết ơn vô hạ, thành kính tưởng nhớ công lào to lớn của chủ tịch hồ Chí Minh, đối với sự nghiệp cách mạng của đảng và dân tục ta.
Người đã cùng ýn cả cuộc đời cho đất nước, cho nhân dân rất đàn ta, nhân dân ta, làm nên những thẳng lợi về văn.
Kì học thứ mời, có khội khoảng 18, khai mặt và sáng nay và dự kìa làm việc trong khoảng 1 mấy ngày.
Kì học được đánh giá có ý nghĩa đặc biệt quan trọng, vừa là bức tổng kết một nhiệm kì nhiều đổi mởi, dân chủ, chắc nghiệm và hiệu quả, vừa là sự trình bị mở đường cho trọng đường của nhiệm kì của khội khoảng 18, với yêu cầu tàn diet và sâu sắc hơn.
Tại kì học này, của khội sẽ xem sẽ, quyết định nhiều nội dung quan trọng, thực hiện công tác nhân sự, gồm bầu phê tròn, mến nghiệm một số nhân sự cấp cao trong bộ máy nhả nước,
dự kìa công tác nhân sự được thực hiện vào những này của ý của tần làm việc đầu tiên.